now to dramatic testimony from the man
who killed ahmad arberry under
questioning from the prosecution travis
mcmichael admitted that arberry had
never actually threatened him before
r-berry was gunned down cbs news has
exclusive new details about this trial
omar villafranco is outside the
courthouse in brunswick georgia with
more omar good morning can't wait to
hear
good morning travis mcmichael was on the
stand for a second day of
cross-examination and then defense
attorneys rested their case but before
they did that one of the defense
attorneys reached out to the prosecution
offering a plea deal the prosecutors
went and talked to the arbury family and
ultimately that request was denied
the prosecution is confident and the
defense is showing some cracks arbory
family attorney lee merritt told us
lawyers for william roddy bryant the man
who filmed the shooting and admitted to
pursuing and boxing in a mod arbory
asked prosecutors for a plea deal late
thursday what does that tell you that
he's concerned about the strength of the
state's case i guess prosecution turned
it down slide out
they want all three of them yeah he's as
culpable as the other two that request
came after the prosecution drilled down
on several key points during travis
mcmichael's second day on the stand how
many times have you pulled up on
strangers that you don't know
next to them with a pickup truck to ask
them what they're doing in your
neighborhood i don't think i have in
that situation including the 25 year old
arbory had never threatened either of
the mcmichaels or brian before they
chased the unarmed black man he has not
threatened you
no
hasn't pulled out a gun
no man hasn't pulled out a knife
he did not
still arms at his sides that's correct
and he's trying to get away from you and
i was letting him run away yes ma'am
prosecutors argued that mcmichael could
have let arbory go instead brian's cell
phone video shows mcmichael outside his
truck shotgun in hand moving around his
vehicle to approach arbury i was
thinking that he was a threat that he
might he might go after myself my father
or the truck so you're telling this jury
that a man who has spent five minutes
running away from you you're now
thinking is somehow
going to want to continue to engage with
you
someone with a shotgun and your father a
man who's just said stop or i'll blow
your head off by trying to get in their
truck
that's
what it shows yes ma'am
we reached out to roddy bryan's attorney
but have not heard back closing
arguments will get underway on monday
tony
omar thank you very much